[MUSIC PLAYING]
YAEL GRUSHKA-COCKAYNE: In
today's business environment,
data is a necessity.
This course will give you an
understanding of data science.
So you think beyond just
spreadsheets and tables.
We will use real world
case studies to help
you understand common methodologies and
statistics, data analytics, and data
science along with some
basic skills on how
to apply them to your everyday work.
SUSANNA GALLANI: The role of
statistical analysis and data analytics
is to provide you with
conversation starters.
YAEL GRUSHKA-COCKAYNE: We will dive
into data wrangling, visualization,
forecasting, and even machine learning.
You will learn how to
design visual models,
develop hypotheses, and draw insights
into actionable recommendations
for your business.
PAUL MATHERNE: What you need
to know as a data science
analyst is that you have to always
be ready to change your model.
YAEL GRUSHKA-COCKAYNE: This will
be taught through case studies
from retail, health care, financial
institutions, and even Hollywood.
TEMPLE FENNEL: I really
wanted to understand the data,
because producing a film can be costly.
But even more costly sometimes
can be the actual advertising.
YAEL GRUSHKA-COCKAYNE:
Not only will you gain
the awareness of the technical
elements of data analysis,
this course will give you the
tools and the methodologies
to act upon the results.
SUSANNA GALLANI: You can
actually maximize the performance
at the individual level.
And in aggregate, you will get a
better performance for the company.
YAEL GRUSHKA-COCKAYNE: Can you
predict the future for your business?
[MUSIC PLAYING]